>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> John Fenn: Hello
I'm John Fenn
at the American Folklife Center.
And I'm here with Huda
Asfour and Kamyar Arsani
and they're going to be playing
in our archive challenge
showcase here in 2018.
So I want to welcome you guys.
>> Huda Asfour: Thank you.
>> Kamyar Asani: Thank
you for having us.
>> John Fenn: Yeah, of course.
And I wanted to start
with maybe asking each
about your individual
backgrounds in music
and then we'll get
to the collaboration what
we're going to hear tonight.
So Huda, we'll start with you.
>> Huda Asfour: I
started playing music
at sort of a young age.
My first formal training
was trying
to learn piano at
the age of seven.
Things didn't go
very well there.
I tried to play a number
of instruments including the
keyboard, guitar, and other sort
of trying different
instrumentation.
And so at the age of 13
I in school I started
to take formal music lessons
and became fascinated
with the [inaudible].
That same summer I took a
trip and had a family reunion
where I met my grand father
who played the [inaudible]
and was fascinated by the
oud, and was fascinated
by the ability to create such a
communal experience for people.
And my family, the friends,
the neighbors, people just kind
of came together around
his singing and his playing
and came back to Tunisia at
the time where I was living,
fascinated by this
instrument and that's
where the journey started.
I started playing the oud then
and then state in the concept
to Gaza and then
later in Ramallah.
While also playing the qanun,
which is a slightly
different instrument,
zither like instrument, and
sort of like my real training
as a musician composer
and delving in more
into the traditional classical
Arabic theory of music came
in later with [inaudible]
in the West Bank
in Ramallah in Palestine.
>> John Fenn: So your
grandfather was your first
exposure to the oud or had
you encountered it before
but not really seen that?
>> Huda Asfour: The oud is
a very popular instrument.
I think it was my first
close encounter with someone
who really played
the instrument.
>> John Fenn: And it sounds like
seeing that community gather
around there was
something that --
>> Huda Asfour: It
was the community,
because I had seen
many oud players
at the time until that time.
So the oud itself wasn't new.
I was very, very much exposed
to many schools of oud,
but it was really truly
the communal experience
that really touched
me, kind of forced me
to look more into
this instrument.
>> John Fenn: And so is that
your primary instrument now?
>> Huda Asfour: Now it's my
primary instrument although I'm
focusing again more on the
qanun in the last few months.
So I would love to bring
that instrument back
into my life more.
>> John Fenn: But the
piano is done, right?
>> Huda Asfour: The
piano [laughing].
No more piano.
>>John Fenn: And what about you?
>> Kamyar Arsani: I
started my music --
well, I think I found
the passion
for music seeing
my dad using half
of his paycheck to buy tapes.
After end of each paycheck he
would go any buy these tapes.
He would bring them
home, explain them to me,
as a child I don't understand
anything but he would explain,
"Yeah, this tape Deep Purple
put it out on this year and I'm
in love with them man.
We got to listen together."
And I think just
the idea of looking
for new sounds was taught to
me by my dad at a young age.
And my mom introduced me
to the instrument of daf,
the Persian frame drum.
And Master Bijan Kamkar, I was
lucky enough to be able to go
to his class and he was --
we call him the father of daf
because he was the very
first person to bring the daf
out of the only Sufi gatherings
and actually bring it on the TV
and as a band and perform it.
>> John Fenn: OK.
>> Kamyar Arsani: So
learned it from him
and I think it was his
progressive mindset when it came
to writing music that is
folklore and traditional,
yet having your own
interpretation of it some sort
so that you can make
it more understandable
for the new audience.
So I think I took that idea from
him as well and went at the age
of 7, so until 7 to 10 years
old I practiced daf with him
and then I learned the
instrument kamanche,
which is the Iranian
bow instrument.
It's pretty much like violin
but you put it vertical
and downward.
And I learned that for a
few years with [inaudible].
But that was my piano.
That didn't go that well.
But the daf became more and
more something that I thought
to myself I should focus on
it because there was so much
to know about it as an
instrument that I was told,
it's 8,500 years old, I wanted
to know if it's that young,
that old, is there more to it?
Is there less to it?
What's happening here?
And I was lucky enough to
play the frame drum, the daf,
in the caves in Khamosha and
Kyrgyzstan a field of Sufi's
and the gatherings of that.
So that gave me the inspiration
to go a little deeper
into just the idea and the
concept to have and the music.
And then that opened the whole
can of worms of all the rhythms
and every amazing thing that
happens in the neighborhood
of my country Iran and
neighbors and everything.
So I started learning the
Afghani rhythms, Pakistanian,
and now with the project
that we have Huda,
I'm still learning day
by day every time we get
together there's ne things.
And so that's my music
background and when I came
to the United States about ten
years ago I just taught myself
drums and ukulele and guitar
just to have fun with it
but then it turned into an album
called, "No Freedom" and then
so yeah, just trying everyday
take a different learning
of things.
>> John Fenn: So what brought
about your collaboration?
How did you guys
come together as --
because you both have
other musical endeavors?
>> Huda Asfour: Jim
Thompson is responsible
>> He is, he is the
wizard responsible.
>> John Fenn: And how long have
you been playing together also?
>> Huda Asfour: Two yeas now.
>> John Fenn: OK.
>> Huda Asfour: So I had been
in the city for since 2005,
left for three years
to North Carolina
and when I came back
Kamyar was sort of --
>> Kamyar Arsani: I
was starting yeah --
>> Huda Asfour: It was in the
city and one day I met Jim
and I think I had a gig with my
quartet at Rosa and he told me
that there's a drum --
there's a Iranian drum player
that I should meet.
So we met --
>> Kamyar Arsani: We met the
night after I think and then --
>> Huda Asfour: And I think we
played like two hours of music.
It was our first encounter so
it was very clear that we come
from very similar thinking
about traditional music,
also very similar deliberate
desire to create more
of a contemporary feel to
this traditional music,
so I think we both know the role
so well so it's easy for both
of us to break them also.
>> John Fenn: So think that
was kind of the catharsis
of that caused this
project to begin.
And do these two instruments,
do they appear together
commonly in?
>> Huda Asfour: I mean
it's not very uncommon
but traditionally the
daf is more played
with louder instruments
than [inaudible],
[inaudible] is not
traditionally a loud instrument.
>> Kamyar Arsani: They're
smaller frame drums
that pair better with
loud and stuff at times,
but then with that because both
mentalities are pushing forwards
and that idea of -- I don't know
we call it the punk attitude
but it's more of a just
taking what you know
and actually risk your time
with it and explore more with it
and I think we have more
faster rhythms and more
like louder ideology when it
comes to that so it's nice
because we take all the ideas
and we shape them into something
where it can be understandable
for younger generation
also it can be something
where you can close
your eyes and you know,
just travel somewhere else.
>> Huda Asfour: Istonically
though the drum usually couples
with either string instruments
like the kamanche or in bazook,
which is a very -- like
very metallic in sort
of high frequency instruments.
We dabbled a little
bit with a kanoon also.
I mean it's always in the mix.
>> John Fenn: OK.
>> Huda Asfour: We're hoping
that the kamanche will make it
into the studio as
well at some point.
So it's expandable also.
It's not necessarily
[inaudible].
>> John Fenn: I mean one
thing that I've noticed
in hearing you two perform
together is this maybe part
of the punk attitude but you
take advantage of the dynamics
of both instruments and are
really sort of engaged way,
but the daf, you know it can
be a very loud instrument.
It can also be a very
subtle quiet instrument.
>> Kamyar Arsani: Right.
>> Huda Asfour: That's
very true.
And but I think because we
both sort of a little bit of --
it is a punk attitude I
think at the end of the day.
For me it's more
influenced by [inaudible].
I've always really loved the
ceremonies, the intensity
of that music, the
trans feel that comes
with repetitive cycles
and odd rhythms and sort
of complex odd rhythms as well.
So I was -- this is sort of
a kind of a passion for me
to delve into a rhythmic
richness of the [inaudible].
And so when we met I think it
just became very obvious very
quickly that this is
something that we have
in common in terms of --
>> John Fenn: OK, so what about
bringing that punk attitude
into the archive, right?
Because we invited
you to come in
and do some research
in our collections.
So what did you find?
What surprised you?
How are you turning
that stuff you listened
to in our collections into
what you'll perform tonight?
>> Huda Asfour: I found the
experience to be interesting
and sometimes a bit
painful I have to say.
Not only from a technical
perspective,
what all the challenges that
come with archive research,
which I think is a
common experience
to whoever would delve
into these archives.
I think what was most
difficult for me as an immigrant
in the country given
the political atmosphere
to understand to the core really
how these archives also are a
presentation of how we
are seen in the society,
in the American society.
And I think that was the
part that was a bit sensitive
and a little bit
difficult at times
because the archives are
very minimalist samples
of the culture that
you know, and for this
to become the presentation
of the culture
in the national archives,
for us,
was a bit of it's a
very limited image
of who we are, you
know, as people.
Because we were looking at not
only the Persian repertoire,
the Arab repertoire, I
was mostly interested
in the Levantine region.
And we found very limited
North African archives.
So some Moroccan archives were
more elaborate in terms of sort
of more accessible also
versus for example like one
of the old Arabic, I think some
of the North African region
had very, very old archives
that were part of
Indonesia trips.
So you know, like it was
just like a passing --
>> John Fenn: Kind of
a sampling of stuff.
>> Huda Asfour: Sampling --
Sampling of a passing of Beirut
that the scholar
was going through.
>> John Fenn: In some of the
collections you were looking
at they were made in the '50s.
>> Huda Asfour: Yeah.
>> Kamyar Arsani: Yeah, right.
>> John Fenn: Which even
I think speaks to kind
of how people were collecting
at a time it wasn't
necessarily comprehensive.
It was, "OK, we're here
let's do some recordings.
We're here."
>> Huda Asfour: Right, but it's
also interesting because most
of the archives are
focused on the folk like --
you know, obviously we are
in the American folk archive
but it is a very sort of
snippet in a way stuck in a time
that doesn't necessarily present
the contemporarily of the times
that it was recorded then.
Right, so you're
in the '40s, '50s.
It's a very charged and very
dynamic political environment.
The whole division is going
through political
transformation,
then what you get of it is only
that very traditional
old folk sense
of what this culture is about.
I don't know if this
kind of makes sense.
>> John Fenn: No it does, but
do you see your guys approach
to the archives like
as an opportunity to be
in dialogue with that.
>> Kamyar Arsani: Yeah, I
want to add to that exactly
to just add to what
Huda is saying,
I think that's why this
challenge became more
interesting for us instead
of just be more challenging.
It was more of a OK,
let's dig deeper.
Let's find out what's going on.
And I think a part of that
problem is it's a part
of the responsibility of the
artists to come in and bring
that awareness and I think
it's great that you guys have
that chance and give it to
artists who come in and listen
to archive and let you know what
you have and what you don't have
and what needs to be
done better with them.
And I think that's why
we thought to ourselves,
all right there is
something here.
And I think that
at the end of it
when I saw other live
concerts from previous artists,
there were times where I asked
myself the question of at
that time it might have
been a good idea to mention
that you are playing the
[inaudible] of Iranian music,
but it's nothing to do with
necessarily when you listen
on the archive, it's what
you have from your repertoire
that you play all the time.
And I think for Huda it was
important not to do that
and take something from
what you guys have and have
that conversation with you.
So I think that was a fun
part of the challenge.
>> John Fenn: Yeah, I like
that idea of there sort
of being a dialogue,
being a challenge,
and being an opportunity
to sort of help interpret.
>> Huda Asfour: Yeah.
>>Kamyar Arsani: Yeah, exactly.
>> John Fenn: You know, two
audiences, two musicians.
>> Huda Asfour: And put it
into perspective, right?
Because it is such a limited
collection, because it's
such a sort of a very
narrow light spot
on a certain dimension
of the culture I think
it's very important
to interpret it as such.
That's not a presentation
of the culture.
It's not --
>> John Fenn: Not of a whole --
>> Huda Asfour: It's not.
It's a very narrow view
of what this division has
to offer in a way.
>> John Fenn: Well,
I'm looking forward
to what you do with it tonight.
And so I want to thank you for
sitting through this interview.
>> Huda Asfour: Thank
you so much.
>> Kamyar Arsani:
Thank you so much.
>> John Fenn: Thank
you for coming in
and doing the research.
>> Kamyar Arsani: Honor to
be here thank you so much.
>> John Fenn: Excellent,
thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.